raciale bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors un nouveau
regain de tension dans le golfe persique
on a l'impression que cet engrenage
mortel entre l'arabie saoudite et les
rebelles aussi n'en finit plus
oui c'est une question de
deux réalisations à chaque fois il ya
une attaque de la part de la coalition
l'aria pas uniquement l'arabie saudite
il ya aussi les émirats harbi arabes
unis auquel la france d'ailleurs vient
de vendre 80 rafale et on assiste oui
c'est ça des réponses et à des niveaux
de violence qui n'arrêtent pas de
demander
la désespérance
des outils
aujourd'hui fait que maintenant il n'y a
plus aucune protection pour les
populations civiles on a vu donc la
semaine dernière que l'aéroport de sanaa
a été bombardé et l'aéroport de sanaa
s'est bien entendu l'arrivée aussi de
l'aide humanitaire
donc voilà
le monde civil disparaît a disparu même
depuis depuis longtemps et cela dans le
silence de la communauté internationale
je vous rappelle que quand même le
groupe d'éminents experts internationaux
et régionaux des nations unies n'a pas
été renouvelé notamment avec un vote
contraire de la russie de la chine alors
la france a voté pour elle et la grande
bretagne ont voté pour mais dans la
pratique la france et la grande-bretagne
sont complices de crimes de guerre et de
crimes contre l'humanité
azer action sécurité républicaine avait
sorti un rapport l'année dernière le 10
décembre dernière pour dénoncer
également les crimes contre l'humanité
maintenant il ya une firme
deux juristes à londres est aussi ont
repris cette qualification de crimes
contre l'humanité et qui s'est engagé à
poursuivre individuellement les
individus mais ce qui nous semble le
plus important aujourd'hui c'était
d'arrêter le flux des armes d'arrêter
les états du nord de vendre les armes à
la coalition dirigée par l'arabie
saoudite et des émirats arabes unis
alors une des une guerre qui dure depuis
maintenant plusieurs années les rebelles
poussés qui sont accusés soutenu par
l'iran ennemi juré de l'arabie saoudite
est ce que finalement aujourd'hui
riyad est en quelque sorte bloqués piégé
dans une guerre qu'elle n'arrive pas à
gagner et dont le prix finalement c'est
c'est toutes ces pertes civiles l'onu
elle dresse un bilan qui fait plutôt
froid dans le dos on parle de plus de
400 mille morts depuis le début du
conflit
wheeler ce même si les évaluations sont
difficiles on peut imaginer
effectivement que
enfin en tout cas le nombre de morts au
niveau de la population yéménite et est
considérable
alors là la difficulté c'est qu'il y a
il y avait une tension à l'intérieur du
gay men avec un gouvernement qui n'était
plus légitime le gouvernement a dit et
des groupes armés notamment les outils
qui
le contester là on était dans une
situation intérieure et en 2015 en mars
2015 il ya une coalition donc deux pays
qui qui arrivait par l'arabie saoudite
et les émirats arabes unis qui viennent
aggraver et ajouter de la guerre à la
guerre
il y a encore une fois
une organisation internationale qui sont
les nations unies et qui sont
complètement prise en otage par les cinq
pays membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité dont la france
elle est partie et
comme cela était d'ailleurs dénoncée
dans les rapports des nations unies les
derniers rapports d'éminents experts des
nations unies
ces pays participent et participe à la
guerre avec leurs ventes d'armes et le
pire c'est que la france s'en vante
emmanuel macron le président macron la
semaine dernière il ya deux semaines
s'est vanté d'avoir vendu 80 rafale aux
émirats arabes unis alors que l'on sait
que les émirats arabes unis
non seulement
alimentent et participe à ses deuxièmes
en plus de ça
alimente al qaïda dans la péninsule
arabique donc on arrive comme ça une
situation absolument
désastreuse est au coeur de cette
situation là les civils malheureusement
ont complètement disparu un véritable
camouflet commune avions écrit dans une
tribune que nous avons envoyé au monde
avec sébastien nadeau
sous blocus a décrété par l'arabie
saoudite une situation qui risque de
s'empirer puisque depuis mardi aucun
avion dead humanitaire ne peut atterrir
à cause justement de ces tirs de mener
par la coalition militaire une situation
à des situations donc qui risquent
encore d'empirer pour pour les civils
qui sont pris en otage finalement
les civils sont souvent noté joue pas
les civils même s'ils ont disparu enfin
puisque même la communauté
internationale n'arrive pas à réunir les
fonds pour pour c'était du humanité
qu'est-ce qui reste aussi vide
aujourd'hui c'est difficile il faudrait
que il est une véritable mobilisation de
la communauté internationale et
notamment des opinions publiques or les
grandes ong internationales ont
complètement disparu dans cette
mobilisation
les grandes ong qui avaient l'habitude
de quand on avait fait cette campagne
pour le traité sur le commerce des armes
il y avait de grandes ong des droits de
l'homme qui était présentée chaque mois
ont mobilisé l'opinion publique pour que
soit
signé un engagement des états ce traité
sur le commerce des armes qu'il a été en
2013 et qui est quotidiennement bafoués
violet notamment par la france et la
grande-bretagne même les états unis ont
commencé à
lever le pied sur les exportations
d'armes en direction des émirats arabes
unis de l'arabie séoudite
ce n'est toujours pas le cas de la
france alors là se pose bien sûr
l'urgence d'arrêter de vendre ses armes
ce que des sommes tous qu'elle voudrait
rendre hommage et que j'avais rencontré
à new york avait soutenu ce projet de
traité on demande donc aux états de
d'arrêter de vendre des armes à ces pays
de participer à ces crimes de guerre
crimes contre l'humanité et puis bien
sûr il y aura le temps de la justice
individuelle et là les présidents
notamment macro les premiers ministres
le castex et edouard philippe et
président hollande valls etc devront eux
aussi répondre de cette complicité merci
beaucoup en tout cas à bruno benoît
mardon exposées - benoît murs à ciel
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes président de lo
ng acer actions sécurité éthique
républicaine